Hello, calculator fanciers
We have a real treat today!
A viewer, a home amateur calculator reviewer, sent me in a calculator I have never seen before
This is the Gaxio!
And they emailed and said: "Have you ever seen a Gaxio"
I said I had not, and they got this shipped to me direct from the Gaxio warehouse
Wherever that may be
And so on the front you can see, it's a Gaxio FG-82MS, very nice
This is a scientific calculator
On the back, you have all the options labeled
It comes... it comes with a slide-on hard case™
Loving that and...
Oh, down at the bottom there - Made in China
Some of you may think the Gaxio is a little bit familiar, looks vaguely like something you have seen before
Well, I have here our previous review we did of a Casio - a member of the FX series
and you can see - a surprising similiarities, look at that
They're pretty much the same calculator, just in different packaging
one's in a slightly cheaper packet than the other
Other fact - you're now watching an unboxing video in an unboxing video
Now, blatantly the calculators cannot
accidentally be this similar
when I saw this it just sent ripples through the calculator fancier community, everyone's outraged
I mean, surely if you're designing a calculator
at least design your own calculator
Don't just rip off someone else's making a cheap version of the calculator
I mean, we are outraged. I will not let this go down
I... I am I could not believe that Casio
just ripped off Gaxio's fantastic design
So let's get in there and see
what the original has to offer
Now, I am a little hesitant to break the
package,  I don't want to have to cut into it
If only it came with a little tab so I could open it
Aah! Here we go, look at that, so I can pop that open there
Look at it just slid out! What an action!
There's, aah,  the inst--
Oo! The instructions are bound.
So often, I open a calculator, the instructions fly one way, calculator the other, I never match them back up again
This, it's all contained, very nice. Put that over there
OK, let's pop the packet open and we have...
(Drum roll please)
OK, so there's the calculator and that slide
on hard case
OK, so you can see already,
this covers a variety of models, so if
you own any of these
And obviously, you're going to have more than one Gaxio around the place,
you can just look them up in there,
very unfortunately it's  for the various FX models
and what we have here is actually the Gaxio FG-82MS, not covered by this set of instructions
Now, you might think this is very suspicious that the Gaxio FG series calculator
comes with instructions something labeled the
FX series and it's Casio as we know who
made the FX series of calculators
OK so that case did indeed slide off
hard... and, oh,  here there's the inset in there
and you can see they've not
glued it in properly, so if you decide
you want to remove it and stick it to the
outside... like so, that is entirely...
Oh, I didn't quite... OK, you get the idea anyways
Look at this, this is the FG series classic, that's good
High quality manufacturing as only Gaxio can do
OK, I don't know who quality control
person 28 are but whoever he or she is,
they know a perfect calculator when they
see one
Right, let's take this thing out for a spin
2 square root... oh it's around the wrong way oh my goodness
OK, O... OK hang on, so... so, 2 square root equals... nice
Times 2... oh OK. so they know if you're typing 2 a second time
you know what you've typed, why waste
an entire part of the display
when they can show you a fraction of it, that.. they've simplified it
Even down here, they've taken chunks off this number here, so you don't need all those extra digits
and you can see, everyone knows the
square root of 2 is 1.411... whatever that is... 13
OK, here we go! 2, equals 31.11... something...ok
*dies of laughter*
OK, OK, hang on, hang on
OK, I'm gonna be honest with you here
31.11... whatever that is... is not quite... 2
But it's not 1.999, so... you know... it's... it's gone different...
In all new and creative ways
let's try something
a bit more down the line, let's put in
π, so we've got π down here,
OK, shift, π, excellent!
And let's just try multiplying it
by one to see if it can do that
Equals 3.141... something... 9
OK OK OK that's OK, that's not so bad
Let's try dividing by 0 and see what
happens here
1 divide 0 equals...
That's... it has a Meth ERROR
so you... this calculator's had too much meth
So when I was testing the inferior knockoff Casio FX
I tried the square root of 17
Square root of 17
you simply type square root of 17 you
hit equals and it tells you that it's the square root of 17
So let's see how this one
does with that square root of 17 equals... a number
OK, let's multiply that by the square
root of 17 and that equals...
Hey, hey! Hey I did it!
OK, I'm doubting myself, I'm gonna to redo root 2 times root 2
equals... two!
What did I do before?
Obviously, the first calculation out of the box is just a warmup calculation,
where it gives you a random kind of test... calibration number
Now it's it's... it's... it's actually I can feel it is genuinely it's heating up
It's now warmed up and ready to go
So as a whole it's quite...
it's got quite a nice hand feel, I mean it's got these these kind of wings, which... which is sweet
And... I mean the Casio calculators,
They're reasonably heavy, they've got
what feels like a lot of plastic
Whereas these
I mean the Gaxio, it's environmentally
friendly
it doesn't use any more plastic than absolutely necessary
It's got a real light kind of... you know...
"could go at any moment" feel
And I... I appreciate that dedication to efficiency in manufacturing
Final scores for the imported Gaxio FX... oh, sorry
FG, none of that knockoff Casio rubbish
FG 82-MS
For display it's got a good display, bits of it seem to come and go all the time though,
so I'm going to give it an 8... or rather most of an 8
For functionality, it's got everything I need that would be an 8
For acuracy, ooh, I wanted to give it a higher score, but it's not quite there every now and then
so I'll... I'll drop the 10 down to an 8
Ergonomics: works well in both hands, I
reckon around an 8
For cred, I mean it's got the Gaxio name, what more do you need? That's an 8
And for durability
*sound of calculator on calculator violence*
Obviously, an 8
That gives us a total score of 888
OK, that's it. Look we're going to very
quickly check that in the instructions
so you can see here... uhm... it's not the English bit... Chinese... Chinese... Chinese...
No English
No other languages
OK,  so normally they have every possible
language,
here, unless you're fluent in Chinese symbols... No luck. That's... that's the Gaxio attention to detail.